yesterday was day two of amy coney
barrett's confirmation hearings to the
supreme court
barrett is donald trump's nominee to
replace the late great ruth bader
ginsburg
barrett couldn't possibly come from a
more different philosophy
than ginsburg barrett is a religious
christian
a member of a cult named the people of
praise who said antonin scalia was the
most in line with her
judicial philosophy day two of the
confirmation hearings
truly a clinic in obfuscation and
deception and what's
stunning about yesterday's second day of
hearings is that i don't think amy coney
barrett actually said anything directly
about her philosophy her answers were
either
saying nothing and explaining why she'll
be saying nothing
or telegraphing her positions in a coy
and deceptive way
while leaving herself complete latitude
to do anything in the future
and all sorts of senators taking a shot
at it just
a pathetic lack of openness sometimes it
was almost comical
and i say almost comical because then
you remember wait
she might be influencing the top level
judiciary of the country for decades
when you're about to laugh you remember
that and you stop laughing
so let's look at some examples there is
speculation that donald trump will
dispute the election
if he does it could reach the supreme
court so chris coons democratic senator
asked barrett whether she'd recuse
herself from any cases related to this
election since it would be an obvious
conflict
having to adjudicate an election in
which the guy who nominated you
is a candidate but she won't she won't
recuse herself
but i think the graviment the court the
the core issue
in recusal is that any judge or justice
should recuse themselves from a case in
which their impartiality
might reasonably be questioned
given what president trump said given
the rushed
context of this confirmation will you
commit to recusing yourself
from any case arising from a dispute in
the presidential election
results three weeks from now senator
coons thank you for giving me the
opportunity to clarify this because i
want to be very clear for the record and
to all members of this committee
that no matter what anyone else may
think
or expect i have not
committed to anyone or so much as
signaled i've never even written i've
been in a couple
of opinions in the 7th circuit that have
been around the edges of election law
but i haven't even written anything that
i would think anybody
could reasonably say oh this is how she
might resolve an election dispute
so she does not commit to that and why
would she i mean there's been no
consequences to anything
any of donald trump's cronies have done
why would she recuse herself no way no
surprise at all
then it goes to cory booker democratic
senator from new jersey
who asks about the importance of
presidents committing to a
peaceful transfer of power something
that presidents
should commit themselves to generally
and she won't answer that cory booker
presses her and she still won't do it
he asked at this time here's another one
do you believe that every president
should make a commitment
unequivocally and resolutely to the
peaceful
transfer of power
well senator that seems
to me to be pulling me in a little bit
into this question of whether the
president has said
that he would not peacefully leave
office and so to the extent that this is
a political controversy right now
as a judge i want to stay out of it and
i don't want to express a view
on so judge i i appreciate you what
you've said about respecting our
founding fathers about the originalism
it's remarkable that we're at a place
right now that this is becoming a
question and a topic but i'm asking
you in light of our founding fathers
and loud of our traditions in light that
everyone who serves in that office has
sworn an oath
where they quote swear to preserve and
protect and defend the constitution of
the united states
i'm just asking you should a president
commit themselves
like our founding fathers i think have a
clear intention
like the grace that george washington
showed
to the peaceful transfer of power is
that something that presidents
should be able to do well one of the
beauties
of america from the beginning of the
republic is that we have
had peaceful transfers of power and that
disappointed voters have accepted the
new leaders that come into office
and that's not true in every country and
i think it is part of the genius of our
constitution
did you see what she did there when
asked about
whether presidents should commit to
peaceful transfers of power
she says the great thing about the u.s
is we've always had peaceful transfers
of power which of course ignores
that we've never had a president like
trump who won't actually commit to one
but she leaves that out conveniently
really interesting moment
when it was senator kamala harris's turn
kamala asks whether barrett
is aware that donald trump has made
comments about striking down the
affordable care act
and is pursuing lawsuits to strike down
the affordable care act and barrett says
she hasn't heard of them but
harris was prepared and harris says well
while you were talking to people getting
ready for these hearings
certainly the topic must have come up
right and this puts barrett into a
pretzel
where she has to admit well yeah i was
told it might come up
but not in the context of trump pledging
to eliminate and
suing to eliminate the aca doesn't pass
the sniff test
let's take a look asked you earlier
today
but did not receive an answer prior
to your nomination were you aware
of president trump's statements
committing to nominate judges who will
strike down
the affordable care act and i appreciate
a yes or no answer please
well senator i want to be very very
careful i'm under oath
i as i'm sitting here i don't recall
seeing those statements but if
let's see i don't recall seeing or
hearing those statements
but i don't really know what context
they were in so i guess i can't really
definitively give you a yes or no answer
what i would like to say is i don't
recall
hearing about or seeing such statements
well i imagine you were surrounded by a
team of folks that helped prepare you
for this nomination
hearing i haven't heard that yesterday
yeah
but let me finish if you don't mind i'm
sorry did they
inform you of the president's statements
and that this might be a question
that was presented to you during the
course of this hearing
when i had my calls with senators
it came up many of many of the
democratic senators
wanted to know about the affordable care
act and to satisfy themselves that i had
not
made any pre-commitments to the
president about it
and so you then became aware of the
president's statement is that correct
um let's see senator harris
in the context of these conversations i
honestly can't remember whether senators
framed the questions in the context of
president trump's comments
perhaps so i think from my perspective
the most important thing is to say that
i have never made a commitment
i've never been asked to make a
commitment and i hope that the committee
would trust in my integrity
so understand that barrett says well
the affordable care act did come up with
multiple senators
but not in the context of what trump
said she wants us to believe
she had multiple conversations about the
affordable care act
without it ever being mentioned that
trump has been on a four-year rampage
including lawsuits to get rid of the
affordable care act
completely not believable now as a brief
interlude
check out this hard-hitting question
from republican senator ben
sass tell us about the scalia ginsburg
friendship
and the the impact that it made on you
really tough stuff
right so that was that was a republican
interlude now back to real questions in
this next one senator dianne feinstein
lanes lays out a question which is
you say you were like scalia scalia
didn't think gay people should get
married could get married legally
what do you think now
you said in your acceptance speech for
this nomination that
justice scalia's philosophy is your
philosophy
do you agree with this particular point
of justice scalia's view that the u.s
constitution does not afford gay people
the fundamental right to marry
senator feinstein as i said to senator
graham at the outset
if i were confirmed you would be getting
justice barrett not justice scalia
so i don't think that anybody should
assume that just because justice scalia
decided a decision
a certain way that i would too but i'm
not going to express a view on whether i
agree or disagree with justice scalia
for the same reasons that i've been
giving
you know justice ginsburg with her
characteristic pithiness
used this way this to describe how a
nominee should comport herself at a
hearing
so that's a game barrett plays she is
smart
where she will cite ruth bader ginsburg
in some innocuous way to avoid answering
a real question and
feinstein tries again on roe v wade
doesn't get any further with it
so on something that is really
a major cause with major effect
on over half of the population of this
country who are women
after all it's it's distressing not to
get a straight answer
so let me try again do you agree with
justice scalia's view
that roe was wrongly decided
senator i completely understand why you
are asking the question
but again i can't pre-commit or
say yes i'm going in with some agenda
because i'm not i don't have any
agenda i have no agenda to try to
overrule casey
i have an agenda to stick to the rule of
law and decide cases as they come
they often use this framing to avoid
answering i'll decide cases as they
as they come up uh speculating about
past decisions you know
so you never get any actual answer out
of them and then lastly from yesterday
there's more but these are some
highlights
here's amy klobuchar asking very simply
do you agree it's illegal to intimidate
voters at the pulse
and barrett says it's a hypothetical
it's not it's simply a question about
the law judge barrett under federal law
is it illegal to intimidate voters at
the polls
klobuchar i can't characterize the facts
in a hypothetical situation
and i can't apply the law to a
hypothetical set of facts
i can only decide cases as they come to
me litigated by parties on a full record
after fully engaging precedent talking
to colleagues
writing an opinion and so i can't answer
questions like that
well i'll make i'll make it easier 18
usc 594
outlaws anyone who intimidates threatens
coerces
or attempts to intimidate threaten or
coerce
any other person for the purpose of
interfering with the right of such other
person to vote
this is a law that has been on the books
for decades so no answer there either so
what did we learn yesterday we learned
quite simply
that amy coney barrett is really
slippery
and will say nothing and republicans
will come out of these hearings say
they were very pleased with amy coney
barrett's performance
let's go and vote her in in all
likelihood
it's what will happen let me know what
you thought about yesterday's hearings
i'm on twitter
at deepakman i want to take a second to
tell you
about one of our sponsors s h masks
snh masks has everything you need when
it comes to
face masks and other protective gear for
covid19
and they're giving my audience 20
percent off snh masks is the company
that i've personally been going to for
face masks i love and trust the products
they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i
also love snh masks because they've
donated
over 60 000 masks to healthcare
institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is free
on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david